[Music]
I don't know what's so far away
[Music]
Town everybody
gosh it really moved me to see Blake get
up Gwen Stefani emotional as her hubby
Blake Shelton reacts to his singer's
performance on The Voice everybody is so
good that's left it's it's the first
time I'm really like I don't know
tonight what's gonna happen the proud
moment happened during Monday's
semifinals as 22 year old Bryce
Leatherwood took the stage to sink If
Heaven Wasn't So Far Away by Justin
Moore
[Music]
and his coach Blake Beyond impressed
bringing the country star to his feet
singing for his family tonight Bryce
Leatherwood everybody
and for his wifey Gwen she couldn't help
but get emotional about it gosh it
really moved me to see Blake get up and
get so excited and I think I think the
reason why you have such you're so
authentic and so kind of classical and
old school and everything that that you
want to see in a country artist and
you're really effortless at the same
time but yet you have this crazy sort of
Star Quality stage presence I'm trying
to live in the moment and Gwen's got her
reasons for why when it comes to Blake
she can't hold back her tears you know
this is a show that I never in my
lifetime would picture me doing
something like this it's been one of the
most fun things I've ever done I love
being a coach I love watching the
contestants grow I love having an impact
you know super inspiring for me and then
on top of it I meet like my best friend
here that's gonna be like forever mine
and there's a lot of like Nostalgia
going on on The Voice Gwen only has one
singer still in the competition Justin
Aaron
[Music]
and it's not even just the singing but
it's it's just the heart that he puts
behind the singing so I just feel
honored to work with him as for Blake he
has three and if Justin by chance goes
home this week it's no surprise Gwen's
rooting for her hubby all the way I have
a lot of people that I'm I'm fans of but
I would say Bodhi is
um I think he's incredible I really do
because I feel like
for my taste I he can he has like this
really skillful voice but he's also such
an artist like alternative artist and
um you can just tell he's just a very
unique person so maybe I would maybe him
but I like Brayden I like I there's
somebody everybody that's left I love
they're all incredible we gotta get a
win for the household let's do it come
on
[Music]